hello everyone and welcome to another
really fun game uh from the saint louis
blitz event uh it's uh well it's a
double round robin uh so this is the
first time hikaru played against magnus
and uh
well it's just a fun game we said that
we were kind of gonna cover at least one
more game
uh and might show more regarding on how
many hashtag suggestions you guys use in
the comments so
uh without further ado let's check it
out uh nakamura with the white pieces
opens with
e4 and magnus goes for the sicilian we
have c5 and he
again goes for the bone cloud uh that of
course is a joke no he doesn't he goes
knight to f3
this is magnus after all we have e6 and
not going for his uh slash nico with
knight to c6
but rather e6 and now d4 hikaru strikes
in the center we have captures captures
and a6 now going for the con variation
sort of like the neither of only these
pawns
traded places and it's a useful move you
prevent the knight from coming here you
prepare b5
the queen can come to c7 if you want so
all in all a very useful move with
bishop to d3
uh by far the most popular move against
the khan variation and bishop to c5 by
magnus
knight b3 attacking the bishop and now
bishop back
all the way to a7 we have queen to e2
and
knight to c6 uh with bishop to e3 just
continuing development
and the d6 and here hikaru just castles
with knight to f6 and now uh c4
is a possible possible move here it is
in fact the most played move in this
position
uh but the most modern way to approach
this is bishop captures uh
on a7 and for good reason however hikaru
goes knight to c3
uh we have castles by magnus and now
rook a to d1
uh we have b5 as planned the bishop is
coming to b7 rook is coming to not there
but
the c8 but now he car played f4 and this
move
has been played only once so this means
that this position has been reached only
once
and it's not a not a very good move but
it is a blitz game so you might
you might attempt it but here magnus
played e5
which is a new move so already as a move
12 we have a completely
new game but there is a better way to
treat this position
now it's uh hard to say why magnus
didn't go for this because it's not all
that
all that difficult to spot uh bishop
captures on e3 one of the reasons why
white's main idea
against this line is to capture the
bishop when we mentioned that
but just captures captures and denied
the g4 and now the queen is cut off
uh completely from this diagonal so you
have to move somewhere g3 or h3 let's
say g3
queen b6 check and after the king moves
93 just wins the exchange now it's uh
it would be uh it would be silly to say
that magnus would miss this line but
maybe he was just worried about
f5 and what happens does he carry get
some sort of an attack here
and of course it's a blitz game you
don't want to waste too much time so it
is hard to say but after a move like f6
white uh will be white will be uh
in some trouble as he will have to give
up one of the rooks
uh but okay here magnus played e5 we
have a completely new game
uh and now hikaru uh takes this
opportunity to eliminate
this bishop as the the same idea still
applies so bishop captures rook captures
and now
f5 and now this is of course much better
than the line
that we've just shown where magnus would
win the exchange so rook d7
of course when you play the sicilian you
must play d5 at all costs so knight to
d5 hikaru
prevents this bishop to b7 and now
c4 are just uh gaining more control of
the d5 square also threatening to win a
pawn here
so b captures on c4 and the bishop
captures and now
uh what you could probably should play
here is just
captures captures and play this slightly
worse position with black
however magnus decides to go uh for a
more
uh attractive approach and he goes for
knight to e7 which means
that he's inviting hikaru to play knight
captures on f6 and open up his king but
okay
magnus says okay after captures i'm
going to play captures and now i'm going
to play king h8 and bring my rook to the
g file
so even though you've messed up my king
structure i'm going to use the g
file for attacking purposes uh but
uh okay hikaru goes king to h1 gets his
king to
uh to a safer square also he he wants to
have the option of rook to g1 at some
point but also
not to worry about any any checks in the
future
so king h8 magnus does the same and now
rook to d3 a very nice rook lift
uh which means that uh you have to worry
about things like uh
rook h3 queen h5 queen captures here
with checkmate also rook g3 queen g4
queen to g7 checkmate
and magnus needs to deal with this hum
somehow whether it's going to be
with some uh bishop c6 to b5 where the
rook to g8
but magnus goes for the for the more
active approach with bishop captures an
e4 and it's a very
tricky line because hikaru captures uh
with the queen
and now uh magnus just goes d5 again
with a double attack
so he uh he wants to trade off as many
pieces uh as fast as possible to
you know eliminate hikaru's attack but
the position is now completely winning
for hikaru so
feel free to pause the video and win
this game for
hikaru while i give you a couple of
seconds
uh so for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on uh
leaving uh well the the bishop there and
putting the queen to the correct square
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show
it's queen to h4 uh not queen to g4 as
then you allow black to defend but queen
to h4
and now it's uh incredibly difficult
because if magnus wins the piece back
with d captures in c4 just rook h3
and there is no way to prevent checkmate
you can just push the pawn a little bit
but just
captures and checkmate or captures and
checkmate uh
it doesn't really matter we can show it
if you don't believe me check
and this will be made so that's what
happens if you capture the piece however
if you don't capture the piece then
you're down a piece but let's try and
defend
uh rook g8 let's say you want to play
rook g7 or something like that and now
you run into queen captures on f6 with
czech rogue g7
and now rook to g3 threatening checkmate
and
once the queen defends just any move
getting the bishop out of harm's way
you're up a piece
you can trade off everything and just
enjoy this completely winning end game
uh so magnus said okay i need to defend
against checkmate i need to somehow win
back material and i need to prevent
queen captures
on f6 so he played knights to g8 now his
queen guards the f6 pawn also he will be
able to play h6 as the knight defends
that
but it's uh of very little use because
here hikaru played
rook to g3 and it was in this position
on move 23 that magnus carlsen resigned
the game
and a wonderful victory for hikaru
nakamura with the white pieces in
23 moves only against the world champion
in all time formats magnus carlsen
uh you could also have gone for rook to
h3 it doesn't really matter
uh it's uh uh the uh it's also
uh of the same uh speed even faster
uh because after h6 queen g34 and now
rook g3 followed by this
is an inevitable checkmate because you
cannot move the knight rook captures on
h6 is instant checkmate
and what you could try after rook to g3
there really isn't much uh
like if you try something like uh h6 is
the same queen to g4
uh and if you don't uh like i said
there's nothing you can do if knight to
e7 this uh queen captures on f6 is
checkmate in one
as the there's no way to block the check
uh and the queen no longer covers the f6
square so of course after rook g3 magnus
resigned and a great victory for hikaru
nakamura so he won their
uh uh the second blitz game uh and
here are the standings uh as i'm not
sure if i'm gonna be showing any more
games
i might depending on how how many games
you suggest
uh but here they are so it's magnus and
wesley so who
won uh shared first so there was no
uh tie break there was no armageddon uh
now we have shared winners and the
magnus cross and wesley so win the saint
louis
rapid and blitz event uh with 24 points
each then uh and uh
wesley still won his last three games in
a row so it was a pretty big deal
uh hikaru in third with 21 points then
with 18 and a half eleven aaron
and alexander grishok uh yanni palmishi
with 18 in sixth then we have a
share in seventeen eight with jeffrey
schengen ventala hari krishna
uh and sharing last place alireza faruja
and linear
dominguez and this cross table here
was made by the saint louis chess club
uh you all heard me say that
so just just in case but yeah
that's the game and this short very
short coverage i did of the saint louis
rabbit and blitz event
i was very busy for the last few days so
i didn't get to cover as many games as
i usually do and as uh as i enjoy but uh
you know
i i do as much as i can
but yeah once again i do hope you
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank bart
carpenter
tom hater to wait uh dirk van morick
sean chadwick and jason clark for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the morphe saga checking up
on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your sunday